okay here we go now better the opponent
from Sweden let's go for kings in yen
again we get the classical again now
even the mainline this more food yeah
okay I only remember what I played back
in the day let's check if this is still
possible this was sort of the main line
now I don't know 15 years ago so a one
main line at least like regroup the
Bishop to e7 to to get everything
covered here hmm is it an idea now to
even take with the bishop King be a 95
oh it's interesting I guess let's try so
we should be seven maybe
yeah but this this looks like a healthy
structure for black or I'd also cannot
enter on c7 in the near future k wants
to detect e6 directly yeah it's not
position anymore for f5 I just need to
play Knight f6 to get e4 attacked okay
hmm
hmm I don't know Queen B 6 could be
really stupid move running into internet
coming to see for
Luxio edges rather passive but not sure
the thing is I don't have much to hear
in this position at what I want to want
to do is to try to to play for an
advantage of possible
yem the simple approach but it should
should actually give me the C file
also prevent night so far the roxy eight
would be of unpleasant pin
besides the fact that you for saying of
course interesting okay
I'm not sure what you did what to do
here this is the really simple way to
play should be fine but I'd really like
to try a little bit but it doesn't look
possible here maybe get the King to help
defend t6
what is he doing I had no idea I don't
think this is a good idea
I can try to get to see Five myself now
yeah night 97 now yeah no more nights
you form of course no it's interesting
queen bee six maybe what the idea to go
to e3 okay covered that but this is no
threat what about f5 is too aggressive
maybe it is
I'm warning try to get the night to h4
mm-hm this looks really weakening
is this a good square
still not sure what to do with the king
e 2 i've got really a lot of checks but
wow check I got this one
I'm completely blind this is just check
made into wow okay completely blind yeah
he needs to go King it too i think this
I don't understand anything King II to
Queen f2 kindy one but what about this
is it so so bad 93 King c1e one chick
King be too I don't get it the computer
gives us is winning already I'm not
winning after King be one
I 91 check of course I said Queen have
to check came to do or not III check
King c1 not Queen you want check King
bee 291 of course yeah then it's a
winning position